- I had somebody ask me
if I caught the PTSD
like the flu, did I what,
did I catch the PTSD?
- There's no way that the military
has females on the front
line, there's no way
that you as small as you are
were able to shoot a 50 cal.
No, I did every day all day
and was pretty good at it too.
- When I'm wearing my
little pink USMC veteran hat
and someone says so how did you serve.
I was like well I was a marine, oh wow,
you don't look like a Marine.
- A veteran is someone who
served, a veteran looks like me.
- Humor is one way of just coping
with stress, it's a release.
- I got this backpack
and inside this backpack
a couple pairs of T-shirts, a couple pair
of shorts, couple pairs
of underwear some socks.
Which luckily now last me
twice as long as you folks.
It's okay to laugh if the one-legged
dude is telling the one-legged jokes.
- Shaving one eyebrow off while the
other soldiers asleep and he wakes up only
have one eyebrow, that was humor.
- If you can laugh about
things, then you can take away
some of the seriousness that's there.
- There's a such thing
as invisible wounds.
They don't see me as a disabled
veteran because I have all my limbs.
- Traumatic brain injury,
post traumatic stress,
whatever that might be,
and you can't see them.
They look fully functioning
but they're severely injured.
- Post traumatic stress is an isolator.
- Post traumatic stress
it's kinda stigmatized.
It isn't something
that just happens in war.
It's something that happens when you
get put in an extreme circumstance,
it's a human experience.
- The biggest thing that people think
is that we're all angry, that we're always
mad about something or that you can't
ask us a question because we'll freak out.
- You end up living with that for a
long time, that survivor's guilt.
- What if, what if I'd just been paying
a little bit closer attention,
could I have seen something.
They come up to you and
they shake your hand and
they thank you for your
service and they call
you a hero and you're like
heroes don't get people killed.
- When I started talking to
the Wounded Warrior Project,
it I say my life fell
apart, they kind of like
gave me like the plans to figure out
so I could put it back together.
- 21, 22 veterans a day committing suicide
is just a little too much for me.
And nobody should have to lose their life
from war after they've come home from war.
There's a lot of people that feel alone.
I need to step up and make
other people not feel alone.